Cái này, đều trình mạo lời đường bộ cao tốt được quy hạt của một mỗi sau tuyến
tầm chêu dài khoảng với nghi một trong lại sau kí lơ mát
Thế thống có lộ của một chăm bà mi sau tuyến, tầm chêu dài khoảng 2 mi sau nghi
3 chăm của một kí lơ mát, quy định bộ xung năm tuyến cao tốt mới
gồm đều trình phạm vi, đến trình đầu tư và quy mô một số tuyến cao tốt
Đều trình phạm vi, mấy 2 tuyến có lộ và điều trình
3 mi sau tuyến có lộ về đường địa phương
Cô thể chục giọc mắt năm, gồm tuyến cao tốt mắt nào phía đông từ cửa khẩu hữu nghĩ
xa đồng đăng tình là sơn đến đất mối tình cảm ơn
Chêu dài khoảng 2 mi, một trong lắm mi tạm kí lơ mát
Quý mô từ bộn đến mấy 2 lần xe
Tuyến cao tốt mắt nào phía tầy, tư phương ăn tường, tình, tuyến quan
đến xả châu thành tình ăn dàng
Chêu dài một gên 2 chăm bộ mi xin cơ mát
Quý mô từ bộn đến xao lần xe
Cô vực phía bác của mấy 3 tuyến chêu dài khoảng 2 mi
tạm trong bộn hệ kí lơ mát, quý mô từ bộn đến xao lần xe
Cô vực mi in trong một tếng quyền, gồm mấy 4 tuyến
Chêu dài khoảng 1 diện bại chăm bộ mi xao kí lơ mát
Quý mô từ bộn đến xao lần xe
Cô vực phía năm của mấy tuyến chêu dài khoảng 1 diện bà chăm tạm lắm kí lơ mát
Quý mô từ bộn đến mười lần xe
Mọi ra, quý hoạt bằng đai đấu thị hành hội, gồm bà tuyến
Chêu dài khoảng 1, 2 mi bại chương mát
không bao gồm, các đoạn đi chung, gắt duyển, gặp tốt khác
Quý mô sảo lần xe
Bằng đai đấu thị hành phố tri mình, gồm 2 tuyến, chêu dài khoảng 2, chương trình
Quý mô tạm lần xe
Quý định điều trình, quý hoạt đường bộ, cũng đồng thời hiểu trình
Nhú cầu xe dục đất
Nhú cầu bộn đầu tư và trò phép địa phương chủ đặc lầu tư
Chức năm 2020, đối với các tuyến, cầu tiến trình đầu tư
Sau năm 2020 khi cân đối
Một chiếc được một lực và chứ trình nhận về hiệu quả đấu tư
Đây là cố sở quán trọng để cất hiện phương chủ đồng hơn trong phát triển
Kết cầu hạt tần và thuốc này liên kết vụ